519 maternité sont répertoriés en france
c'est trois fois moins que dans les
années 70 des fermetures successives de
maternité une tendance qui s'installe
dans l'hexagone dès 1972 à l'époque le
gouvernement souhaite renforcer la
sécurité des mères et des bébés le
décret daineche impose alors aux
établissements des normes d'encadrement
plus stricte et un nombre de 15 minimum
pour obtenir l'autorisation d'exercer
difficile donc pour les petites
structures de résister en 1975 la
maternité d'auxonne dans le département
de la côte d'or faisait partie des
condamnés il ya une législation
hospitalière qu'il faut quand même
respecter et appliquer la maternité
dawson ne répond plus aux normes des
maternités tels qu'on les conçoit
actuellement un sort que des centaines
d'établissements connaîtront ensuite des
fermetures mais aussi des regroupements
de maternité regardez en trois ans le
nombre de maternités était déjà passé de
1747 à 1369 une chute qui continuera
jusqu'au milieu des années 90 à cette
époque les petites maternités sont
toujours pointés du doigt
pour simone veil alors ministre de la
santé les mères et leurs bébés n'y était
pas en sécurité
elle préconisait la fermeture des
établissements avec moins de 300
naissances par an ce médecin dénoncé une
manoeuvre économique
ce sont des mesures qui ont tendance à
regrouper les maternités pour des
raisons uniquement économique
alors je voudrais bien qu'on nous prouve
que nous sommes dangereux tous tes
petites maternités avant de nous fermer
quatre ans plus tard en 1998 le seuil
minimal d'activité pour une maternité
est officiellement fixée à 300
naissances
un chiffre difficile à atteindre en zone
rurale et qui menaçait une nouvelle fois
les maternités de proximité on sera
obligé d'aller dans des centres beaucoup
plus important où il y aura justement
certainement passer de chaleur avec avec
le personnel et puis cette confiance
aussi dans les années 2000 le nombre de
maternités continue de sûreté et les
petites structures continuent de
disparaître
aujourd'hui les établissements de moins
de 300 accouchements ne représente plus
que 5 % des maternités loin très loin
derrière les moyennes et les grosses
structures en 2017 la maternité de die
dans la drôme et est elle aussi menacée
des femmes enceintes manifester leur
colère
je vis à 2h de valence j'ai pas envie
d'accoucher au bord de la route ou mat
ma vie où la vie du bébé en danger quoi
l'établissement de 10 n'échappera pas à
la fermeture
face à la disparition des maternités de
proximité certaines femmes optent pour
les maisons de naissance dans ces lieux
ni médecin ni péridurale
seuls des sages femmes libérales assure
le suivi des grossesses et des
accouchements
autorisée depuis 2000 15 9 maisons de
naissance sont aujourd'hui répartis sur
le territoire
[Musique]